ja willkommen zur virtuellen
ersatzsitzung im Seminar philosophische
Theorien der Aufklärung
zunächst wie immer der Rückblick was
hatten in den letzten Sitzung wir hatten
uns mit Gotthold Ephraim Lessing befasst
der ein Werk verfasst hat mit dem Titel
die Erziehung des Menschen Geschlechts
aus dem Jahr 1780 das war der erste
deutsche aufklärungsphilosoph Lessing
ist ja auch bekannt als Schriftsteller
Nathan der Weise ist der einer dem
anderen sicherlich bekannt was hat damit
auf sich Lessing ist insofern
verschieden und überhaupt auch viele
deutsche aufklärungsphilosophen von der
französischen Aufklärung das was sie die
Religion eine wichtigere Rolle spielt
ebenso auch die Bildung wir haben die
ausgeklappe die diskutiert die hatten
sehr skeptischen Zug ähm was tut wer sie
ist und davon merkt man jetzt bei der
deutschen Aufklärung nicht Religion noch
eine größere Rolle und auch vor allem
die Erziehung aber auch die Menschheit
also so eine
menschheitserziehung ein
menschheitserziehungsgedanke der ist
immer sehr zentral und das ist das
Titelbild Titelblatt und wir haben ein
paar Leitfragen wie verhalten sich nach
Lessing Vernunft und Offenbarung
zueinander wie und was versteht Lessing
und eine Erziehung des
Menschengeschlechts auch kommt bei ihm
der Begriff Aufklärung vor und da hatte
ich schon ein bisschen was gesagt zum
letzten Punkt zum Verhältnis zur
französischen Aufklärung er ist nicht so
religionskeptisch
ja wir haben hier ein paar Paragraphen
alle die ganze Schrift jetzt sind es
Menschen Geschlechts besteht aus
Paragraphen aus der kurzen ganz
interessant paragraph 1 was die
Erziehung bei dem einzelnen Menschen ist
ist die Offenbarung bei dem ganzen
Menschengeschlecht die Offenbarung sind
natürlich die Offenbarungsreligion
Judentum Christentum Islam das sind also
ähm
schriftreligionen die von sich aus
behauptend das Wort Gottes zu vermitteln
weiterzugeben und jetzt kann man sich
natürlich fragen inwiefern kann man
Offenbarungsreligionen
im Sinne eine Erziehung des Menschen
Geschlechts sehen und Lessing
parallelisiert jetzt
Offenbarungsreligion mit
individueller Menschen Erziehung
und
die
menschheitserziehung geschieht durch die
Offenbarung nach Lessing permanent sie
geschah schon der Vergangenheit sie
geschieht jetzt und sie setzt sich fort
mit der zukunftigen Generation aber auch
die zukünftige Generation gehört
natürlich zu Menschen Geschlechter zu
das Interessante ist jetzt am Vergleich
zwischen Offenbarung und
Erziehung dass die Erziehung oder
genauer gesagt die Vernunft dass die
Vernunft zu denselben Ergebnissen
gelangt wie die Offenbarung also dass
ich Vernunft Offenbarung nicht
widersprechen aber dass der Menschheit
durch die Offenbarung früher und
schneller und vielleicht auch
zuverlässiger zu dem Wahrheiten kommt er
spricht jetzt hier nur die Dinge man
kommt zu dem Dingen ich vermute mal das
ist die Wahrheit
also die Offenbarung die ist eine
beschleunigte ähm Vernunft könnte man
sagen eine andere Erfassung der Realität
unmittelbarer direkter während die
Vernunft nur mittelbar zu den
Ergebnissen kommt länger braucht
umständlicher Umwege vielleicht auch
brauchte so ist das Verhältnis zu denken
und es ist ganz wichtig sagt jetzt
Lessing das die Offenbarung die
religiöse Erziehung der Menschheit dass
die nicht einfach willkürlich erfolgt
oder die Menschheit überfordert das ist
ja auch immer das Problem mit der
Erziehung sind dass sie ein gewisses Maß
beachtet hat dass sie also didaktisch
angemessen war für die Menschheit das
ist auch eine These von ihm
dann ist für ihn ganz interessant dass
in den nächsten Paragrafen
nach Lessing die
Erziehung der Menschheit durch die
Offenbarung nicht alle Menschen sofort
Betracht die gesamte Menschheit sondern
nur ein einzelnes Volk und das ist
nachlässig das Hebräische folgt das eben
erst noch in Ägypten war und da sehr da
sehr schwierigen Situation lebte und
dann praktisch ganz von vorne an
gebildet und erzogen werden musste wie
ein kleines Kind sagt Lessing und dann
verschiedene Stadien durchmachte und das
Problem war bei dieser Erziehung
hebräischen Volkes die Erziehung zum
Begriff des einigen Gottes also das
monotheistischen Gott das bedürfte sagt
Lessing einer sehr komplexen Erziehung
weil natürlich so ein Begriff des
allmächtigen Gottes sich nicht ohne
weiteres aufdrängt das ist ja das
Spezifikum der drei
Offenbarungsreligionen schon Christentum
und Islam
die Vernunft hätte Probleme sagt jetzt
lesen sich so ein Begriff zu bilden
natürlich musste diese Erziehung des
Hebräischen Volkes nach Lessing
schrittweise erfolgen sie konnte nicht
gleich zu viel verlangen also es war
eine sehr didaktische Erziehung
und Lessing
spricht dann davon dass
ein glücklich organisiertes Kind
Erziehung genießen muss und das ist mit
langsamen aber sicheren Schritten
anfangen muss das ist also ganz wichtig
bei der Erziehung dass man nicht zu viel
verlangt
ich gehe noch ein bisschen weiter
es geht darum dass man einen richtigen
Maßstab hatte und das auch die Vernunft
letztendlich wie ein Paragraph 36 sagt
selbst auch die Offenbarung erhält das
also Vernunft und Offenbarung nicht
nachlässigen einem Widerspruch stehen
und das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig zu
betonen dass also nach Lessing
Aufklärung und Religion Vernunft und
Religion sich nicht widersprechen
sondern in einem ganz komplexen
pädagogisch erziehungstheoretischen
Verhältnis mit Blick auf den einzelnen
Menschen aber auch auf die gesamte
Menschheit stehen das zeigt überhaupt
die deutsche Aufklärung aus dass
Religionen Vernunft siede Aufklärung
nicht gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
wir haben das aber auch schon bei der
französischen Aufklärung gesehen in der
aussieht glaube die das auch hier die
Opposition von uns Religion nicht so
eindeutig ist sondern das durchaus auch
Zukunft mit Blick auf die Religion eine
Rolle spielen kann
ja es gibt verschiedene Schritte der
Erziehung sagt jetzt Lessing und blickt
da natürlich auf die Geschichte
hebräischen Volkes wie es in der Macht
christlichen Begriffen Alten Testament
vorkommt und so wurde dann aus dem Kind
plötzlich der ein Knabe also es hat hier
eine Entwicklungsprozess gegeben
hier ist jetzt ein Paragraph 18 wir
haben einen Sprung gemacht und
interessantes Zitat was die Aufklärung
betrifft ich lese es vor sind bei dieser
eigenen zigkeit des menschlichen Herzens
auch den Verstand nur allein an ihm üben
wollen was unsere körperlichen
Bedürfnisse betrifft würde ihn mehr
stumpfen als letzten heißen er will
schlechte Dings an geistigen
Gegenständen geübt sein wenn er zu einer
völligen Aufklärung gelang und diejenige
Reinigkeit des Herzen hervorbringen soll
die uns die Tugend um ihre selbst will
zu lieben Fake macht
also es geht darum dass wir eine völlige
Aufklärung brauchen nach Lessing und
auch eine Reinigkeit des Herzens also
Aufklärung
und Moral stehen gemäß diesem
Erziehungsideal im eng Verhältnis und
das betrifft natürlich auch das Problem
auf das wo so hingewiesen hatte ich mach
oben rechts in den Kreis zu dieser
Sitzung der gesagt hätte Aufklärung darf
nicht auf Kosten der Moral des Herzens
erfolgen brauche noch eine Aufklärung
des Herzens aber die Kritik bei sowas
gegenwärtig Aufklärung seiner Zeit hat
das Herz vollkommen vernachlässigt
und das verlangt jetzt aber gerade
Lessing dass es menschliche Geschlecht
auf die höchste Stufe der Aufklärung und
Reinigkeit kommen soll die Reinigkeit
des Herzens als auch die Moral des Herz
wird häufig mit der moralverbindung
gesetzt heute geht es um einen weiteren
Aufklärer deutschen Aufklärung nämlich
Johann Gottfried Herder und er hat eine
Schrift verfasst mit dem Titel Ideen zur
Philosophie der Geschichte der
Menschheit hier sieht man wieder dass
Geschichte eine Rolle spielt Erziehung
und Geschichte war ja auch verwandt nach
Lessing und die Menschheit wird wieder
eine große Rolle so sah der gute Mann
aus und das ist das Titel Blatt seiner
Schrift
wir haben ein paar fragen in welchem
Verhältnis stehen nachher der Menschen
Tier
worin besteht nachher die Bestimmung des
Menschen das sind so Fragen die auch bei
Lessing aber auch bei lametrie vorkommen
sagt Herder über den Menschen
augenscheinlich hatte Eigenschaften die
kein Tier hat und er hat Wirkung
hervorgebracht die im Guten und Bösen
ihm eigen bleiben kein Tier frisst
seinesgleichen aus Leckerei kein Tier
mordet sein Geschlecht auf dem Befehl
eines Dritten mit kaltem Blut natürlich
das menschliche Tier macht das kein Tier
hat Sprache wie der Mensch sie hat noch
weniger schriftverletzungen Religion
willkürlich gesetzt und rechte kein Tier
endlich hat auch nur die Bildung die
Kleidung die Wohnung die Künste die
unbestimmte Lebensart die ungebundene
Triebe die flatterhaften Meinungen womit
sich beinahe jedes Individuum der
Menschen auszeichnet als man sieht hier
es gibt große Unterschiede die aber
nicht immer zum Positiven die Menschen
gereicht wenn es zum Beispiel auch um
das Böse geht also der Mensch ist dem
Tier im Guten wie im Bösen überlegen der
aufrechte Gang sagte der Weite des
Menschen ist die einzig natürlich ja er
ist die Organisation zum ganzen Beruf
seiner Gattung und seine unter
jeden Tag und sein unterscheidender
Charakter der aufrechte Gang das ist
nach Herde des Wesen des Menschen das
was ihn unterscheidet von anderen Tieren
und diesem aufrechten Gang macht er sehr
viel fest
der Biber sagte baut aber Instinkt mäßig
seine ganze Maschine ist dazu
eingerichtet sonst aber kann er nicht
sie ist das Umgangs des Menschen der
Teilnehmer an unseren Gedanken und
Leidenschaften nicht fähig der Affe
dagegen hat kein determinierten Instinkt
mehr seine denkungskraft steht nicht am
Rande der Vernunft am Armen Rande der
Nachahmung er nahm alles nach und muss
also zu 1000 Kombinationen sinnliche
Ideen in seinem Gehirn geschickt sein
deren kein tierfähig ist dann weder der
Weise Elefant noch der gelehrige Hund
tut was sie zu tun vermag er will sich
vervollkommen der Affen aber er kann
nicht die Tür ist zugeschlossen die
Verknüpfung fremde Ideen zu denen sein
und gleich sind die besitzmähung des
nachgeahmten ist seinem Gehirn unmöglich
also der Affe steht schon knapp unter
der Mensch das natürlich auch aus
evolutionsbiologische Sicht sehr
spannend die Herde so natürlich noch
nicht kannte die gab es natürlich erst
seit Darwin 100 Jahre später
die ganze Proportion sagt Herr der Weide
der organisierten Kräfte des Tiers ist
der Vernunft noch nicht günstig in
seiner Bildung der tierischen Kräfte
herrschen Muskelkräfte und sinnliche
lebensreiz die nach dem Zweck des
Geschöpfs in jede Organisation
eigenverteilt sind und den herrschenden
mit der aufrechten Gestalt des Menschen
stand ein Baum da
dessen Kräfte so proportioniert sind
dass sie dem Gehirn als ihre Blume und
Krone die feinsten und reichsten Säfte
geben sollte interessanter Vergleich
Mensch mit aufrechten Bau und Krone mit
jedem aderschlag erhebt sich mehr als
der sechste Teil des Bluts im
menschlichen Körper allein zum Haut der
Hauptstrom des selben erhebt sich gerade
und krümelt sich sanft und teilt sich
allmählich also das auch die
entferntesten Teile des Haupts von
seinem und seine Brüder strömenden
Nahrung und Wärme halten sehr
interessante Metapher der Mensch als
Baum als baumblume mit Kronen natürlich
Krone der Schöpfung wohin alles Blut
hinstrebt als diese strebensrichtung die
aufrechte Streben Richtung nach oben
natürlich auch zum Himmel natürlich zu
den Ideen und der Freiheit kurz der
Mensch sagt er ist was ist ein soll und
dazu Teile ein aufstrebender Baum
gekrönt mit der schön die Krone a einer
feinen Gedankenbildung also die
aufrechte Gangart des Menschen deutet
schon hin auf seinem Kopf auf seine
Gedanken die darüber hinausgehen also
eine Transzendenz ist hier bereits in
der physischen Organisation sichtbar
das war sind wir für die heutige Sitzung
ich bin gespannt auf die Diskussion
gerne auch unten dann auf Youtube und
ich freue mich auf die nächste Sitzung